am I good in the shot yeah yeah all
right so uh yeah Singapore body tracing
horizontal with a bit of vertical P body
traces in there um covered a ton of
ground uh a fair amount of it does kind
of review some of the other videos that
put out but let's try to get it all
together in this particular work
workshop um we started out with uh just
reviewing Archer weaves which is taking
a normal weave stepping back into more
of a pener stance so that one arm is out
stretched the other one is weaving more
around the armpit and
shoulder it helps if you turn your torso
to move the arm from side to side which
creates more space so that this one can
weave the shoulder and armpit more
comfortably from here we can start
tracing a lot of people have maybe
played with this sort of thing where
like you can switch
stances switch
which one is traced in we actually focus
more on tracing the arm without
switching
stances so here it is this is an
anti-race and we'll cover why that is in
a
moment still doing a 3 be weave but it's
tracing along the arm kind of contrary
to the boy
motion this is the one most a lot of
people find this naturally but what we
actually played with was the antenas of
that was
a pro spin or ins spin Trace so from a
forwards weave I'm basically starting on
top of the armpit and in one circle from
over to under tracing out and back
resetting out and
back that's much that's very much like
an extension or a linear extension the
other flavor is actually to do a bit of
isolation so I'm actually poking the poy
head down isolating around poking the
poy head up isolating
around so real quickly
to to show why that's anti-race and pro
trce one way to think about this is if
you take a circular flower pattern like
maybe I'm doing this box mode anti
spin I take the circular hand path and
flatten that down
so that it's a very thin oval just
around my arm it seems very linear but
it's still a flower it's just a
flattened flow so if you actually look
for
that you know here's the Box Mode
unflattened and here it is flattened
around my arm but if you really look for
it you can actually see The Petal pedal
petal petal so there's a pedal there
pedal there
pedal under the P pedal ear pedal under
the armpit the ins spin tracing
version is I'm doing this
one that's actually kind of like I'm
doing a two pedal in spin with the top
and bottom pedal and I just flattened
those pedals down so they're going over
and under the
arm another way to think of this too is
if if the pois wheel and it's rolling
along the surface of my
arm this is
going in the direction I'm rolling in
the direction the wheel is spinning and
that's an in or Pro Trace but if I'm
going contrary if the wheel is grinding
against the surface that is an
anti-race that's another way to think of
those so we started out there but then
we expanded to both sides of the body on
the home side it's actually going to be
more shoulder snakes on the cross side
it's tracing an Archer but we focused on
specifically making it through all four
holes all through four zones over the
shoulder under the armpit over the home
shoulder under the home under the home
armpit over the home shoulder um without
leaving any out so we get really a full
full
framework so we can go from let's say we
go from reverse spin here
snake to the shoulder hop over the neck
so you're going to lean the neck back a
little bit hop over the neck immediately
back behind the shoulder so it never
really fully came in front then you can
do your in spin Trace Pro trce around
the arm now you go from uh armpit Trace
around torso to armpit and out again so
it looks like this
Bo don't
and of course we also want to do if this
is the reverse arm we want to do the
forwards arm so that's going to snake
into the arm around the Torso to the
other armpit in spin prot trce prot
trace or in spin Trace uh right over
here to the shoulder around the neck to
the shoulder and
back and then we can start playing with
those we can take
turns uh one goes
around gets home the other goes
around gets
home like
so and we can also start throwing in if
you know
this shoulder snake thing you can throw
that in for a little extra flavor into
this sort of sequence as
well then we played with turning with it
so so I think the best way to start to
learn the Turning is a very step-by-step
thing you're going to go let's say we go
under the armpit under the other armpit
which means you have to get crossed
up and then you switch
stance which also switches which arm is
near and far then unwind
unwind next arm hops in over the
shoulder switch stance arm
wind boom boom
boom bo bo bo bo like
so and once you're comfortable with that
you can actually
omit this is almost like a lockout beat
or an extra rest beat that stance switch
you can actually just do the stance
switch in one beat instead of two so it
could look like
like
that
was I don't think there was anything
major else that we covered with that we
started getting into anti tracing
now uh all right yeah so side
note um we touched on this basic plane
control practice for spinning behind you
both because it's really useful for a
bunch of stuff and not everybody here
played with it but also
specifically because it illustrates
anti- twist or anti- turn in the wrist
so when this arm is twisting up behind
me the wrist is twisting the same
direction the poy is spinning it gets
awkward though when you keep the poy
spinning the way it's spinning but you
start
untwisting the wrist my wrist is now
twisting contrary to the way the PO is
spinning and until you practice that
it's going to feel weird and awkward and
you're probably going to flail around
and just skip over it but it's a really
useful skill to have and if you're going
to do anti- traces with your poy you are
going to experience this weird wrist
anti- twisting thing so what does the
anti Trace look
like instead of snaking under the
shoulder here we're going to drag it
back to the shoulder then we're going to
trace almost like a smile
face around the neck immediately behind
the cross shoulder then we do the
anti-race just like we were with the
Archer weave now we're going to lean
back a little and TR carry it around the
Torso under the
nipples immediately back behind the
armpit and here's the awkward part now
you're going to extend out while your
wrist your arm uncurls and wrist is
turning contrary to the poy see it again
boom boom boom boom boom over
and and notice how I'm I'm kind of in
this position where my body is almost
turning away from it to protect my arm a
little bit oh my plan's getting really
wonky um and what I do is I kind of turn
my
torso turn my torso and unwind the arm
and that when you get it nicely it looks
nicer and I think it it's also really
sharing the load on your body and
shoulders
having to twist contrary to the poy it
protects your shoulder doing this too so
we're here and it kind
of I'm turned that way and I turn the
other way and that helps protect the
shoulder then
reverse so reverse immediately goes for
the really awkward
position traces around the armpit does
the Trace around the neck and back if
that really awkward position is hurting
your shoulder sometimes maybe you can
just sort of cheet it that way like do a
normal in spin Trace but like a little
low down so it looks like it's anti-
tracing that that can save your shoulder
if it's hurting so we can do easy way
then anti-race if you
want or you can do it the God it's so so
clunky there we go the hard
way where you have to be be careful of
your shoulders like so then you put them
together
cheat so
freaky and then you can turn oh that way
well it's been a little while since I've
done this one anyway whatever I've got
that other video where I'm better at
doing the
turn but you you can also do the
continuous turning and racing the whole
time um and then you can mix a
match so once you get comfortable with
all these building blocks you can also
come across the body so part of it's an
anti-race part of it in spin or you know
you could be in spin here then here an
anti
trce all right so we can we can
essentially start drawing zigzag
shapes around the the arms and just
playing with what different flavors come
up but in order to do that easily you
have to take some time drilling the
basics so you're not completely butting
your head against the wall when you're
trying to do all this Criss-Cross stuff
um one one one of the fun slash
ridiculous things that switch so okay uh
that we can do is combine one anti-race
and one in trce the non-lit poy will be
the in trce the anti- spin the lit Bo
will be the anti trce one so here we are
here's
ingrace here's an
Trace here they are playing whoa that
was sluy
together am I missing my rhythm there
what is going on there we
go anyway yeah fun stuff can happen
there um then we let's see was there
anything else we did verticals yeah okay
so vertical Trac is like this sort of
thing or this sort of
thing um they're easier to learn not
Wall playing but learning them wheel
playing so really as you snake around
your shoulders your shoulders are making
a subtle turn from here to
here so if we exaggerate that it's
easier on the shoulders and easier to
start learning so instead of just
standing here in a wall plane
boom I'm going to turn the way my
shoulders were
moving anyway you play it I'm just it's
almost just like a shoulder reel like
this so I'm just bringing it from
reverse I'm bringing both hands to the
shoulders and then extending after I've
turned around so touch the shoulders
turn around extend the arms in the other
direction pretty much that simple and as
you get comfortable with that you can
start to add more is a right right now
it's just sort of touch and
go as you get comfortable with that it
can really become a little more
isolated what's nice is when you learn
by turning instead of just standing
still you could go back the direction
you came from but you could also keep
turning it puts you in a position where
you can do another Trace so so from
reverse we're going to the shoulders
that means from forwards we're going
into the
armpits reverse shoulders
forwards
armpits the forwards one is particularly
it's kind of weird because here show you
this way the hand that is up in the air
spinning forwards that's the direction
you're going to be turning towards as
that happens not only you have to bring
down to the armpit if you just did that
it'll wrap around you you're going to
turn into it run into it so you have to
trace down to your armpit and do a hip
reel push back behind you like that so
it's actually that you flick your PO
head behind and then your body turns and
catches up so this is a case where the
pad leaves and then I
follow so it looks like this push behind
boom that is it's actually something I
didn't really fully talk about I'm going
to throw this in there really quick um
whenever you isolate whenever you have
both hand and py head movement and that
is crossing back and
forth you have a situation where you
could have a hand Le or a head Le like
ISO so if I'm doing this I can see how I
can do this crossover my hand is always
leading dragging the Pye head or I can
flick see how I'm fli the poy head
leading first the hand is chasing there
two different feelings they're both
isolations they're both weaving back and
forth but those are two different
feelings most people are more used to
dragging most people are used to kind of
like getting like this and coming around
where the hand leads and drags the POI
after it that's why this one is this is
tricky because you have to take this poy
head and sort of flick it at an angle
behind you it's almost like a little
mini plane Bend there's a moment where
you're forcing it at an angle so the poy
head gets ahead of the whole game and
then you isolate after it and flatten
out again so that it doesn't stay at
this angle it's just there for a moment
just to get there and then you've
flattened out again so that's actually
what's kind of happening to get back
there so clean and
quick and that's the that's the case
with all these shoulder snakes too when
when you're when you're putting them
behind you you're having to get used to
how to like flick the toye heads behind
you and then let your shoulders catch up
but from Back to
Front you're just dragging your hands
and the poye heads
follow and most people don't think
really consciously about that they just
sort of do it until their body's kind of
doing it but when you really consciously
realize that like some snakes have to
force the pyad to lead and that feels a
certain way and some snakes have to drag
the poy head that feels a certain way
you can really troubleshoot it and feel
into it a lot quicker what's going on um
what else did we do weird combinations
of flowers and stuff oh my god well okay
let let me quickly show you this like
opposite direction thing that looks like
the G
move if we do this turning you can turn
all the way to here and then come back
or we can turn all the way to here and
then come
down or we can get all the way to here
and like maybe do a cap
can trace
across or maybe we can do some anti
spin so this whole turning through the
vertical Trace gives us options from
here I
could got this anti spin flower and that
was sloppy but I could trace
it like so
basically there's a lot of lot of lot of
possibilities tracing depending on which
way you turn you can come out in spin
you can come out anti- spin you can once
you get to a tea you can stop and do
some of the horizontal
tracing and then you can start combining
them all together uh this guy's a limit
um and then I showed some other weird
half-ass combos but that was all sort of
jibber jabber so w attempt it on the
camera again um anything else was there
any last last bits I miss saying no
good okay sweet I'm going to go pass out
now